[Music]
fifteen years ago if you thought it was
a good idea to pay strange men to drive
around your fourteen-year-old daughter
you would be laughed out of a room now
parents are more comfortable with their
daughters going into Ebor than driving
themselves we were going through major
major consumer shifts you got your
perspective good morning I'm really
excited to be here for many different
reasons one we have a good amount of
time for this keynote so I'm going to be
able to create some context - I've had
the great pleasure I run a thousand
person marketing agency and Chase Bank
has been a great client for a long time
so and I've been very close to that
account and even before that had worked
with a bunch of people in the credit
union industry on their marketing
strategies so I always enjoy when I have
much more context of the day to day so
that's a lot of fun and and three just I
had an incredible breakfast with a small
group of people that are in the audience
and just the the quality of the
questions and the vibe in general excite
me so thank you for having me this
morning thanks for being up I got in
late last night
from New York and noticed a bunch of you
were still running around a little bit
later and so that fact that you're here
this morning is impressive many
different places where I want to go one
I'm gonna give you a little context of
how it got here because I'm gonna assume
a lot of you don't know who I am but
number two I think a great way to start
this talk is very simply this you're
about to find out that I grew up in the
liquor business and launched one of the
first e-commerce wine businesses so I
grew up in an unbelievably regulated
business my entire career I've had the
great privilege of working in the
financial sector for some of the biggest
clients in the world over the last half
decade and the thing that keeps ringing
in my mind as I was getting up this
morning is I think it I think in 2019
as we head into the next decade I I
think this needs to be the conference
this needs to be the moment this needs
to be the time that this collective room
starts really putting their mind in this
place where they realize that using
regulation as an excuse to not innovate
is not a sustainable strategy I think
the reality is that so many people in
this sector default into blaming
regulation as an excuse to not learn the
new communication portals that matter to
our end consumer I stand here today and
the reason I started a marketing company
a decade ago was because marketing for
me a decade ago after investing in
Facebook and Twitter and Tumblr after
being an early investor in uber and
being a bit big better on Netflix when
it went public
you know I genuinely believed that there
are so many innovations upon us whether
it's blockchain whether it's
peer-to-peer whether it's online
competitors there's so much innovation
from a business standpoint it's so
difficult for so many people here to go
back home and really rejigger their app
or their website to be lacking the
friction needed to compete in a 2020
world this is like practical in the
trenches stuff but the one place that is
very practical to begin the battle that
is needed for the companies and
organizations here to compete in the
next year let alone next decade the one
place you can adjust quickly is your
marketing strategy and marketing spend
it is hard to go back and rebuild a tech
stack infrastructure it is much easier
to go back and cut your direct mail
budget in half then allocate it
somewhere else this is a very important
time in this industry it's a very
important time in our society there's a
there's a real massive naivete in the
collective of understanding that the
Internet is the middleman and that
everybody else is just waiting for their
time to be exposed books got picked on
first but then along the way you know I
was saying this morning just
only six or seven years ago I was in DC
giving a keynote to the black car & taxi
industry desperately trying to get them
to understand that uber was a problem
and what everybody did in that
conference is what everybody does in
every industry which is they come up
with the excuses or concepts that they
hope the customer wants instead of the
reality of the customers needs the
reality is if you're in this industry
and you create any friction towards a
transaction for an end consumer they're
not interested we value time as again
back to my investing career I invested
nine years ago in venmo right when I
think about the dynamics that that
played out and that one didn't work out
as well because it didn't operate to its
success it's sold early and in branch
tree really made the dollars but the
thesis was right and the reason so many
of the things that have happened in my
career have worked out is because I am
blindly consumer centric anytime you
think about what's in it for you versus
what's in it for the user of you you're
already vulnerable and I do believe that
we are upon a very important decade of
technology innovation that only building
your actual brand will be able to
compete against we are only a decade
away from at scale so many of our
customers making financial decisions
through the Alexa or Google home or
apple pod in their home and when you
understand what that toll booth looks
like it's gonna make Google search of
the last decade seem like child's play
so let me take a step back and give you
a framework because I actually think
five minutes of context of how I got
here will help you understand what I'm
about to push that I think you have to
consider I was born in the former Soviet
Union I came here when I was three years
old it was a super hardcore lifestyle I
mean I lived in a studio apartment half
the size of the stage that I'm standing
on right now with seven family members
my dad got a job as a stock boy in a
liquor store and used to drive from
Queens to New Jersey for two bucks an
hour which just tells you how cheap gas
used to be and and it was really it was
a hard course
I went on one family vacation my whole
childhood we finally moved to Edison New
Jersey about five or six four or five
years in six five years into America
because my dad became the manager of a
liquor store in a town next door that is
where my entrepreneurial career began I
am I started a lemonade stand and then I
should be honest here I manipulated my
friends to stand behind the other five
lemonade stands I created so I had a six
lemonade stand franchise and and for
everybody here over the age of 38
you might remember big wheels those
little things that we used to ride as
kids I used to ride my big wheels to
every one of my locations at the end of
the day to collect my cash like I was
Tony Soprano or something
so that's who you have on stage actually
now I'm gonna go I appreciate the laughs
so I'm actually gonna really bring it to
you actually six months before that
business my first actual business was
going into people's yards ripping their
flowers out of their yard ringing their
doorbell and selling it back to that so
not not the proudest year of my life but
but I was super entrepreneurial I'm 43
so I had the benefit of being of the age
when baseball cards and sports cards got
really big and was a huge phenomenon and
when I was 12 years old at that point
I'd already realized that I was an
entrepreneur even though every other
immigrant was getting straight A's
I was getting D's and F's my mom was an
is just amazing and built an enormous
self-esteem but she was super frustrated
by that part so she really said that if
you're not gonna be a student you're
gonna have to learn how to work so I
worked a lot but you know for me this
was not the golden year of
entrepreneurship again depending on what
age you are you know that the 80s and
90s was the college you go to as a
direct attribution to how successful or
good you are so I was making two to
three thousand dollars a weekend at at
these malls in New Jersey yet all my
parents and all my my friends my parents
friends all my friends parents and
definitely all my teachers told me I was
going to be a loose
I don't know about you guys but when you
have $37,000 in cash under your bed when
you're 12 years old and you're not
selling weed you're not gonna be a loser
that one's for all the parents with DNF
students out there don't worry guys it
can work out it's cool anyway and you
know it's funny the way I look at school
in the modern education system and the
way that college is structured and the
debt you have to incur to get a piece of
paper that no longer translates to an
actual job that makes it ry+
is a lot of the way I think about being
a traditional financial service provider
in today's environment when you're not
leaning in to the infrastructure of the
web let alone let alone and all of you
know this like the amount of VC funding
and private equity money being put into
FinTech and competitors and layers above
and like cloud and we're not even
talking
forget about Bitcoin or cryptocurrency
we're not even talking about the
manifestation of a mature blockchain
there's so much pressure on us
collectively in the macro what what I'm
affected by is the next part of my story
when I turned 14 my parents said okay
the baseball card thing is a fad which
they were right about you need to start
working in the family business so I went
from making $3,000 a weekend to making 2
to 3 bucks two to three dollars an hour
bagging ice in the basement of my dad's
liquor store so I call those the Dark
Ages I hated it
my dad ran his liquor store like the
Soviet Union so his employees didn't
necessarily love him so the 14 year old
son that looked 9 really took the brunt
of that so is it was a tough era but
eventually when I turned 16 I was
allowed upstairs because I was relegated
to the basement and bagging ice and
something amazing happened I realized
that people collected wine even though
my dad's store was called shoppers
discount liquors we were in an affluent
part of New Jersey Short Hills Milburn
summit Livingston some dollars in the
neighborhood and they would come to the
store and they would ask for these
expensive wines me being bored started
reading about wine
that connection cuz I wanted to help my
family business made me realize there
was something there a passion and so by
the time I was 18
no 18 year old should know as much about
wine as I did I was off-the-charts wine
book smart and then I went to school
freshman year September 1994 I'm in my
dorm room playing Madden 94 dominating
by the way and and my friend runs in and
he says you have to come and see this at
this point I had already been really
helping my dad I had a lot of knowledge
I was a good salesman on the floor and I
was gonna open up 800 shoppers discount
liquors right I was gonna build the
toys-r-us of liquor stores is kind of
how I thought about it as a 17 18 year
old now I'm in a dorm room in September
of 94 and I get pulled out of my room
and I go look and I see and hear for the
first time clue couch
pretty for the under 25 under 30 set
here you missed one of the great rackets
in business history America Online used
to charge 3 bucks a minute to be on the
Internet
though they gave you a CD that gave you
eight trillion three hours it was the
first time I saw I said something
ridiculously stupid like is this the
information superhighway or whatever we
called it back then I had heard a bit
but at this point I'm 18 years old just
to put into context and I'm sure this
resonates with a lot of people in this
room I'd been on a computer for 20 hours
in my life because of classes it was
just not a part of my lexicon or my life
but what happened next was super
interesting within an hour of being on
the internet but the first time in my
life I found myself on a bulletin board
selling sports cards and I realized that
this was going to be what I was going to
do and so on intuition and and just
tasting it I launched one of the first
three e-commerce wine businesses in
America 1996 when I launched
winelibrary.com and rebranded my
family's business this is where it gets
important here my objective here today
is to not worry about the macro issues
potentially over the next two decades
because for a lot of executives and
operators here you won't be around to
see that play out anyway and that's not
practical and I have no interest in idea
your futurism I care about general
practicality I believe the biggest ROI
that I can bring here today is help
people understand alternatives of what
they could be spending their money on to
communicate to end consumers to do
business with them that is what I'm
passionate about an everyday basis
I have no emotion you'll hear me talk
about LinkedIn and Facebook and Twitter
and YouTube and a bunch of things in a
little bit
I have no emotion to them I could care
less of Facebook and Twitter and YouTube
are around tomorrow or not the only
thing I do and it's not up here but when
you saw my slides earlier it says I day
trade attention the only thing I care
about on an everyday basis is where is
the consumers attention how much does it
cost to get to them and how and what
creative do I need to put in front of
them so I can get their business but I'm
not emotional about it
I built my family business this way I
took a business that was doing 3.8
million dollars in revenue 10% gross
profit so you can imagine how little
money was left for marketing I took a
business that in 1998 when I left school
and started operating my dad's business
on the back of winelibrary.com on the
back of email marketing and then on the
back of Google AdWords which were the
two big innovations having a website
doing email marketing in the late 90s
early 2000s raise your hands so for the
OGIS that just raised their hands do you
remember those open rates I mean I had
an email newsletter how many people have
done email marketing in their career
raise your hands high wait to hear this
in 1998 I had a 200,000 person
newsletter that had 91% open rates what
I know more than the Sun will come up
tomorrow as I know that marketers ruin
everything as a marketer I ruined email
I remember my email newsletter when I
first innovated I'm like maybe I can
email people and so I emailed like 80
people and we sold way more wine and
then I was like wait a minute
that didn't cost me anything like the
catalog that I used to send out the same
that sell the same stuff cost me a
fortune I remember from 1998 to 2000
sending so much email because I was
convinced that eventually we would
charge for it like it was it was so
remarkable
and I went from emailing once a week to
three times a week to five days a week
and then a year two years later I was
like people read email on Saturday and
Sunday so we went to seven and then I
was like maybe you can send more than
one email a day systematically from 1998
to 2007 I destroyed our email newsletter
but on the back of that and on the back
of buying all the wine terms on Google
AdWords a day it came out how many
people here have done Google ad
marketing in their lives so the day came
out it was five cents a click for about
four and a half months before $0.10
became the base I literally owned every
word from wine to Cabernet to Merlot
this is where the story of my career is
devastating I'm very proud that I built
a very my family liquor business from a
three point eight to a sixty million
dollar business in seven years with no
capital with no VC money as a matter of
fact and you'll love this this crowd
will love this my dad's so old-school I
didn't even know that credit lines
existed so I built a business from 3 to
60 million on making every penny work
its ass off that was email and Google
AdWords that's what I'm gonna talk to
you about today how do you make every
penny work its ass off how do you not
and I think everybody will resonate with
this following line the greatest thing
that's happening in marketing right now
is that we put the past on a pedestal
and we demonize the current we put the
past on a pedestal tried and true we
create [ __ ] reporting to justify the
spend and then we ask stuff that has
real data to prove that it works that is
ludicrous and that is why we're seeing
so many companies lose market share and
decline it's because the executives
behind that feel comfortable with what
got them there instead of understanding
that's exactly what's gonna make them
vulnerable and that you should be
required to continue to up your game and
learn new skills and understand how new
things people like Gary but I understand
how Facebook works I'm like figure it
out dick
like isn't that business like like isn't
that the merit of what we're doing here
like the reality is that's what's
happening so I built up that business on
the back of those two platforms that was
the my life that's kind of how I did it
and then a very transcending moment
happen to my career and then we'll go
into tactics YouTube came out I'd
already built this huge business and I
saw it and I'm like this is interesting
it was about four or five months old and
I started a wine show called Wine
Library TV i sat in front of a camera to
rank four bottles of wine for 20 minutes
gave my opinions about it and hundreds
of thousands of people decided to start
watching it a couple funny things about
it and this is the number one thing and
we just had this at the table right
before I came here the reason most
people struggle with contemporary
digital marketing is because they're in
sales mode not providing value and
building brand mode your transactional
it's like what did this post get me its
CAC and LTV it's math it has no brand or
LTV dynamics in it what I was that
person remember the reason I told you is
think about where my DNA started rip the
flowers sell it right not good well
great business models sat on inventory
for no time high margin but but not not
good morals what I thought on February
21st 2006 which is when I first taped
the episode of wannabe TV what I thought
I was gonna do was do QVC right how many
people here grew up in the New York
tri-state area back in a day how many of
you remember crazy Eddie I thought I was
gonna do crazy at he meets QVC I was
gonna be ridiculous and myself and I was
gonna sell wine the camera goes on this
is literally five seconds said if you
literally go to youtube and type in Wine
Library TV episode one you can almost
see it I know myself I don't know if
you'd pick up on it but somewhere around
one minute into the video I'm like wait
a minute
this is being recorded and will be on
the internet and will be around forever
I can't sell I have
actually give my actual opinion on these
wines and so the reason I became an
internet phenomenon and why it exploded
was I was literally going on the
internet every day five days a week to
hundreds of thousands of customers and
potential customers and panning the
wines that I was selling in my own store
at times I was being an editorial voice
not a transactional voice what that seed
created for me is something I want to
talk to you about but what's really
interesting to this story and how we got
here today is YouTube sells to Google
for 1.7 billion dollars I read an
article I'm super blown away by that
number I don't know if you guys remember
when that transaction happened that was
a no7 like it was a very different world
back then 1.7 billion feels like a
trillion today it just seemed ludicrous
90% of the world had never even heard of
YouTube it was this big thing and in the
article it said angel investor Ron
Conway makes X amount of money on his in
twenty five thousand dollar investment
like two hundred twenty five million
dollars something ludicrous and I
remember thinking man I've been so right
about email and Google AdWords and now
YouTube I need to become an angel
investor and in 2007 and 8 I started
doing that and the first three companies
I invested in were Facebook Twitter and
Tumblr
so I'm rich
but more importantly than that is what's
what happened next was instead of
becoming a VC and I I mean you guys know
this dynamic on the back of an and uber
like I was rolling and instead of
raising two or three hundred million
dollars on a fun getting to points
making all that money just to take
meetings and having 20% of the upside
which is what most of my friends did
from that era I decided to build a 2020
version of Mad Men client services
shitty business terrible yada makes no
sense to all my smart friends but the
reason I did it is why I find myself
here today I believe there is a gross
underestimate on how substantial the
consumer behavior shifts are and are
about to be if you think a lot of things
have changed over the last five to seven
years and they have in the way we behave
in the way I mean dating 15 years ago if
you online dated you were the weirdest
nerd in your mom's basement now it is
like standard to swipe left and right
24/7 365 are behaviors in our society 15
years ago if you thought it was a good
idea to pay strange men to drive around
your fourteen-year-old daughter you
would be laughed out of a room now
parents are more comfortable with their
daughters going into Oberer than driving
themselves we're going through major
major consumer shifts and all the things
that were tried and true are being
pressured by technology this industry is
on the precipice of being disrupted
dramatically forget about macro
technology trends just on competitors
that look like Amazon and others it's
all coming because the services continue
to be commoditized as the technology
advances if you play out the chess moves
of that it's the same thing that's
happened in politics it's the same thing
that's happening in transportation it's
the same thing that's happening to book
stores the wine industry what everybody
in this room eventually will realize and
I'd be very grateful to get an email in
35 years and be like huh I didn't really
believe you but now in hindsight I'm
surprised how it played out you were on
it I believed one man's point of view
that if you play out the chess moves of
the advancement of the inner
and technology the only thing we are all
left with is brand the only thing we
were all left with is brand and why I
decided to build a client service
business and learn marketing was I was
an entrepreneur in Silicon Valley winner
but I knew nothing about fortune 5,000
land I didn't understand why the money
was being spent the way it was being
spent and I needed to go get my hands
dirty and taste it and over the last
decade and ironically today's the
10-year anniversary of the business my
brother AJ and I started called
vaynermedia I've learned a ton of stuff
most of it is disappointing to be honest
most of the reason money is spent as
political and defense and trying to rise
up the ranks I used to be mad at you the
individuals now are mad at the system
right the machine makes people do that
I'm so tired of CEOs and seat and board
members coming up to me and saying Gary
I so believe in your progressive
marketing I'm like it's practical it's
not progressive they're like fine like
your progressive marketing but I can't
get my executives to execute it's my
people I go no it's you employees are
easy I don't know guys if you've seen
this but it works tremendously well if
you're in control you just change what
people get bonus Don yeah thanks mom you
know like like literally at dinner it's
like a fortune 500 CEO the other day and
she was amazing she's amazing and she's
like I'm just so frustrated like we I
can't get my people in like good news
instead of your bullcrap internal mmm or
Nielsen brand stuff lyft or sentiment
analysis all these like there's nothing
that anybody in this room is held
accountable to from a reporting that
they don't understand that it's deeply
flawed and easily manipulated bull right
you all know this right I mean how many
more meetings do you want to be in where
the reports like our sentiments
tremendous but our business sucks crap
and so you know I said to her I said
look if you so believed in LinkedIn and
Facebook just change the bonus structure
just change the rules like I have a
funny I big idea I guarantee that your
CMO and your brand managers are gonna
spend a lot more money on Facebook if
you put a bonus in place that the
you hit this much Facebook spend you get
bonus so like we have enormous control
to change the game yet people are
undereducated
doing away people are here this morning
that have massive points of view on
Facebook marketing but have never spent
the dollar on Facebook and seen the
results of it we live in a world of
headline reading there are people here
of strong points of view of Facebook
Google YouTube LinkedIn all these things
predicated on headlines you know many
people run up to me they're like Gary
what about Cambridge analytical I'm like
what about it Ron Ron has no answers
target and IRS and visa breaches put out
tons of data but we have it is a huge
misunderstanding of what consumers are
actually doing I'm watching the ven Mo's
and the Robin Hood's and the rocket
mortgages and the blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah giraffe this and like
brands that are built out of nowhere I
know kids that are building 87 different
URLs for nine bucks an hour like credit
house income home dot org running
Facebook and Google Ads and taking
customers and making margin on being
referred like the consumers attention is
very clear it's this you may not like
that it's this you as a human Karen and
Rick you might not like that at dinner
your kids on the iPad the whole time two
things on that take the iPad away and
stop complaining to it's the consumer
you don't get to pick watching people
make executive decisions on how they
wish the world was versus what the
actual customer is doing is one of the
most fascinating things to me of all
time right like I literally had a
meeting three or four years ago where
the guy was like Gary you know like I
hear you on this Instagram thing but I
gotta be honest with you I just don't
get it and I go that's cool John but
you're a 68 year old old white dude and
currently the people that use it are 16
to 24 year olds I don't know if you
remember during this breakfast but
you're the CEO of a company that sells
to 16 to 24 year old women
this dynamic is amazing the amount of
companies in this room that have not
taken have not taken the leap into
contemporary marketing is fascinating
and it is completely predicated on one
to do things in this room it's very
simple it's just the truth for the
majority not everybody
it's either a the internal machine
doesn't score it positively and that
head of marketing CMO or VP or whatever
it may be doesn't want to fight the
system and conforms even though she or
he doesn't believe in print or radio or
outdoor or whatever else commercials
they do it because that's what the
Machine accepts and there's no reason
after 15 years of great work for them to
make themselves vulnerable to fight that
fight and so they just conform or be if
they have the autonomy they're not
comfortable in these new environments
because they haven't been practitioners
of it themselves and they're not sure or
see they've run some Facebook or Google
or YouTube ads and it wasn't successful
and on a small test they decided the
whole thing doesn't work the ROI of
anything is predicated based on how good
you are at it how many people here are
familiar with wish the shopping app
raise your hands high how many people
have never heard of it raise your hands
high which I'm gonna assume oh do me a
favor let's like make a rule because
we're about to do some QA to rules this
morning
no half-ass hands and - there's no
judgement here it's just data for each
of us like there's no reason to here of
wish like I know if I'm asking it or
like oh I don't want to be in the not in
the know so real quick one more time hi
how many people have heard of wish to
shopping app look around everyone just
to get a sense great that's a lot
actually now put your hands down how
many people have not ever heard of it
raise your hands high appreciate it
thank you so wish depending on who you
believe is doing between six
conservatively and 12 billion dollars in
revenue it's a shopping app they spend
all their money on Facebook ads ninety
five percent the only things they've
really done that maybe you've seen is
they have the patch on the Lakers Jersey
and during the MacGregor Mayweather
fight they had the logo in the corners
and in the middle of the Ring twelve
billion nine six at this point
somatically does
matter it's probably one of the only
potential long-term competitors of
Amazon yet most people still don't know
it exists because the way they did
marketing was underpriced attention in
facebook the disproportionate I promise
you if everybody here knew how to do it
there's a lot of nuances and we'll get
into some QA and like but if everybody
knew how to do it
5-mile radius of your branches using the
data to find your you know your
prospects if everybody here really knew
how to be a modern-day Facebook and
LinkedIn marketer your business would be
dramatically different there is no radio
or local television or outdoor or direct
mail campaign that fires better than
those two places when you understand
creatively what to do the flexibility of
these platforms to put content out that
resonates with the end consumer because
you're targeting people of certain
incomes or certain genders or things of
that nature is just too remarkable to
overcome for the other platforms that
require Vennela your direct mail
eight-by-twelve is the same picture to
everybody that same message you're
trying to get across of why your branch
is so awesome just a mile away
needs 39 different pictures and videos -
39 different segments psychographically
and demographically on facebook that's
why it converts if you make one video or
picture on a five mile radius it acts
more like direct mail and radio this is
about knowing guys ROI of having the
skill the ROI of a basketball for LeBron
James
is going to be over a billion dollars
for me it's negative 3000 I've torn both
of my new meniscus to me that's the
punchline so what I'm passionate about
is getting this room to understand that
they need to figure out something that
is practical to become a modern-day
marketer for example let's talk about
underpriced attention these are
platforms that I believe if you spend
money on are a better deal than if you
spent it somewhere else then the words
or the videos become the variable if
it's successful number one podcasts how
many people here are actively listening
to podcasts raise your hand actually
don't do me a favor it is important if
you listen to a podcast
and it can be many different one or the
same one if you listen to a podcast most
of the week like two or three times a
week or more stand-up just do me a favor
let's get the blood flow going stand up
if you were actively listening to
podcasts we're talking about 66 the
middle is a little weak
alright thank you you can sit down for
me one of the most interesting places to
market right now is podcast if you're a
bigger brand in the room because
obviously some aren't but if you're a
bigger brand buying pre-roll I've read
podcasts right now on shows that you
think hit your demographic or
potentially as narrow as financial shows
as broad as something that might be
considered high net worth if you're
looking for that world whatever maybe
you've got to make those decisions but I
will tell you this there's a great
misunderstanding right now the worth of
pre-roll podcasts because the data isn't
clear yet of how many people are
listening or watching Apple is not
really reporting yet in that youth in
that blurriness what I always deploy is
common sense I know people are listening
to podcasts at scale I know that the
companies that have been actively
marketing on podcasts the last two years
MailChimp things of that nature are
growing on it on the seth rogen show
they're growing dramatically one of the
things that as you can imagine as a
street kid from an immigrant family one
of the great devastating things that has
happened in our society and this is
based on seventy years of prosperity we
have eliminated common sense from our
businesses do you know me people here
live their life as a human one way but
then as soon as they go into the office
say completely different things about
their marketing who here can't wait to
leave Vegas run home and carefully go
through their direct mail guys I don't I
mainly work on fortune 500 the budweis
actually how many people here happen to
see the Dwyane Wade Budweiser video that
made everybody cry raise your hands so I
appreciate that so that's a vaynermedia
execution that we're super proud of what
I'm Way more proud of is more than any
Super Bowl ad or anything else they've
done on television the sale
of Budweiser in Miami and ironically
Chicago where he's from and he played
for a few minutes have exploded right
yep I mean a lot of people saw it the
costs were much less and here's where it
gets crazy we didn't even have to spend
on Facebook and YouTube that heavily
because when you make great content it
travels itself there is no commercial on
television or newspaper ad or cold call
that goes viral there's no taking that
and passing it on as all of you know
word-of-mouth is the foundational thing
to business and that is the great thing
social media in our society today and
it's something I've been talking about
for a decade I am not naive or unaware
of where everybody wants to position it
it's because Americans don't like to be
held accountable for anything so when
the banking crisis happens it was your
guy's fault right not me even though I
was a hundred thousand dollars in debt
making eighty seven thousand dollars a
year and thought it was a good idea to
buy a five hundred thirty seven thousand
dollar home in a decade we're gonna
blame colleges for collapsing because
all the college debt but it's not gonna
be our fault for not being self-aware
and understanding that $80,000 in debt
for a piece of paper that doesn't get
you a job as a bad deal and that so that
is what I spend a lot of time our
inability to be held accountable and so
I just think it's a very interesting
time in marketing I highly recommend
looking at podcast number two LinkedIn
LinkedIn is gonna feel natural for this
crowd because it feels more mature older
you know great I'm thrilled if you
follow my content for last ten years as
an everything my last book I didn't even
have a LinkedIn I had a chapter on every
platform I'd even put LinkedIn in it
because it was so irrelevant only twenty
four months ago
for a niche group of b2b businesses
there was a way to go over the last
twenty four months it is transformed
into a content platform for all shapes
and sizes business I've pushed fitness
experts to go put out LinkedIn content
of like three tips when you travel it's
become literally Facebook seven eight
years ago where the organic reach of
your content can go much further than
you can imagine
we believe that every bank credit union
and financial advisor if they're
building a personal branding here needs
to have a very significant LinkedIn
strategy but the content that comes out
has to bring value you need to think of
yourself as Bloomberg you need to think
of yourself as the New York Times you
need to think of yourself as Fox News
you need to think of yourself as content
not as a salesperson you need to put out
content that builds awareness and brings
value to somebody eight ideas that you
should be thinking about when buying a
home six ways to hack a business loan
things that actually bring value to
people you can do that now as you think
about your team and your agency partners
you have to become very self-aware you
need to think about a couple things
number one you absolutely have to think
about how do you communicate best I do
it through video and then I strip the
video and make audio and that's how I do
my podcast but I'm not a great writer so
I get interviewed by my writer and then
it becomes first person not everybody
has to do everything best but you do
have to be self aware of how you
communicate to your end consumer the
written word voice and video have always
been and will always be the three
platforms you have to decide how your
organization is going to do that best
the other thing is you have to audit the
people that are executing this how many
people here work with outside agency
partners raise your hands great this is
a big one this is a big one now that
I've been in the industry for last ten
years one of the things that has been
very obvious to me is that most agencies
are incentivized to make their own
margin which means by nature being a
client service provider has a disconnect
of misaligned interest a lot of the
advice you're getting and the reports
that justify it right now are completely
predicated on that agency's margins the
reason that television and programmatic
digital continued to be the beacons for
the biggest companies in the world is
because that's where all the margin is
for the biggest media agencies in the
world and even for small shops they will
always reverse engineer to their biggest
margin because I built vaynermedia for
myself because my long-term plan I
didn't mentioned
earlier with my agency is not was not
only to learn but it was also to take
advantage of the next economic downturn
because I believe everybody's so grossly
over leveraged because we didn't
properly pay the piper in 2009 that I
believe that there's gonna be some
significantly great deals to be bought
when the world melts and earlier that
whole rich thing how many people here
are immigrants or kids of immigrants
raise your hands so for the small hands
that went up immigrants have figured out
a really interesting trick it's called
sit on cash and it's funny you know my
financial advisors and I have a lot of
friction because I do very high-risk
investing and then I sent them way too
much cash for their liking but my point
is I'm gonna make that cash work for me
I'm patient I'm gonna wait for the next
economy to collapse and when that
happens all of a sudden four million
dollars acts like sixteen sixteen
million dollars acts like 160 there is
no compounding value on the market or
anything else that makes it work that
way if that's what I want to do with my
money so I think that there's a really
interesting thing of why my agency's
been able to figure it out is because
I'm building it for myself to buy things
and run it through this is how I figure
it out why was everybody giving such bad
advice guys if your company is buying a
banner ad on a website that is mainly
seen on a desktop not on a phone below
the fold you can't waste money faster
there's not a please if you do any as a
matter of fact leave now leave the
conference leave my talk go back to the
office and stop any cent spent on banner
ads on websites
it is a literal joke as much as I hate
television commercials cuz watch this
watch this not 16 year old crowd you
ready watch this by show of hands how
many people here now mainly watch when
they watch television Netflix Hulu
Amazon or HBO or when it's on video on
demand and you fast-forward commercials
raise your hands Netflix raise them high
keep them up I want everybody in the
front and these fancy couches to look
back
guess keep them up for a second can we
all agree that the majority of people in
this audience aren't 14 teenage 14 year
old teenage girls this audience almost
95% of you don't even have a chance of
seeing a commercial forget about if you
consumed it and got inspired to do
business 95% of this older crowd is not
even got a prayer of seeing an actual
television commercial 60 billion dollars
spent to make you buy things in America
on television commercials then you've
got digital banner ads nobody who here
does click the banner ad can somebody
razor and some the only banner ads you
click are once I went to your website
you got me in the funnel you retargeted
me and then you annoyed the living [ __ ]
out of me to buy those socks or take
that mortgage and then I clicked it it
is not a consideration funnel it is a
retention and retargeting funnel we are
broken in marketing in 2019 the reason
the toys-r-us is in the sears of the
world and you'll see it every single day
in every market it's coming guys
it's coming and honestly it's actually
here and you know what I'm most worried
about how much damn margin and how
profitable the companies in this room
actually are the biggest thing that I
struggled to push a new agenda in
marketing is the current results of
businesses when I spoke the toys-r-us
eight years ago they were thrilled with
their business they didn't want to hear
it this is what happens every time the
only audience I'm worried about when I
go pitch a new client or speak here is
one that is currently successful that's
what happens things are always good
before they're bad and so I just don't
understand the following if you believe
50% of what I'm saying
the reason I started a marketing company
not a build a technology company is
because it's the easiest thing to change
it just is
you can go home and change it you can
and I think the days of like I mean I
literally have clients that are spending
more money on outdoor billboards than
they are on Facebook and Instagram I
don't know if you got when you leave
this conference can you please just look
at everybody who's driving on the
highway let me promise you this every
single person that's a passenger is
looking at their phone so I think we can
all agree in 2019 versus 1999 billboards
should not have gone up in price at
least half the audience has been
eliminated from seeing it the scarier
part when you look at people driving if
you happen to do this which is what I do
is half the people driving or looking at
their phone you guys are scary out there
we we are not deploying common sense
behavior against what's actually
happening with our consumers and that is
why we were becoming long-term
vulnerable now let's go into you're
buying in find Gary I'll call your bluff
let's talk about YouTube real quick one
of the greatest ad products in the world
today is a specific product that YouTube
has which allows you to target people
who searched on Google something and
then go to youtube to watch something
completely different they searched for a
mortgage or a loan or a bank or whatever
on Google and then three days later they
go to watch a UFC clip on YouTube they
go watch a ski clip but the pre-roll is
you before they watch that they
literally type in looking to you know
looking to borrow some money and
literally you're pre-roll before their
ski video is hey are you looking to
borrow some money and they're like holy
[ __ ] how'd you know
it's an incredible product I highly
recommend you look at it the key though
is it's very hard to make a compelling
video that gets somebody excited this is
one big game once you get into the
framework of understanding how
underpriced the digital landscapes
certain digital landscape products are
the game that you're going to get caught
in to is
a lot of people are here spending a lot
of time thinking about their media
agency but they're not spending time
thinking about the content they put in
there the most important word in today's
digital centric world of marketing is
context this is one big game of having
enough content to match the 30 to 80
different psychographic and demographic
cohorts that are potentially doing
business with you this is a very big
deal
what we have not committed to in our
industry of marketing is spending enough
money or spending money properly to make
enough pieces of content it is
remarkable for me to watch early-stage
startup companies out market much bigger
companies because they don't know any
better because they're just living in an
Instagram Facebook YouTube world you
will be blown away what happens when you
put a asian american in the picture or
video and then target asian americans
with the same message and then run a
separate ad with an african-american
female in it and you run it against
african-american females in a five-mile
radius then an african-american male 18
to 21 gets a different message than 58
to 63 then income levels there is a
graph a framework of 40 to 70
significant segmentations in our society
and then not to mention the subtle
nuances of your neighborhood I'll give
you a weird one if you mark it in a
certain part of Illinois and and
Wisconsin like if you use Packer lingo
vs. bear lingo or vice versa the
conversions on your sales are ludicrous
and through the roof if you're a
national brand look I think we all know
what the political climate there are
clearly two very different points of
view on the current state of America
your marketing needs to reflect that
people value different things we
understand that in our social issues but
as marketers we're trying to sell
vanilla to everybody this is one big
game of content that's contextual to the
platform LinkedIn organic content you
need to start an editorial like
capability in your
Zain Facebook you could hate it you
could think sucks is the worst you could
think the Russians you can think
anything you want but when you're in
business you you start realizing a lot
of things here's my favorite thing
everybody's out there saying screw you
Facebook and they're posting that on
Instagram headline readers versus
practitioners people like to play hero
on social media but then don't back up
their actions the actions are very clear
right this second Facebook is the single
best place to market in the world
because people are still not pouring
enough money on the platform because
they're making emotional decisions
versus practical business decisions I
could care less about Facebook I have
way more snapchat and Pinterest stock
things that I don't believe are doing as
well I want to be historically correct
and I will stand up here in ten years
and say you're still running ads on
Facebook and Instagram they're
overpriced what's great about Google and
Facebook and Instagram and snapchat for
that matter and Pinterest is it's a
marketplace ads start at a penny and
then supply and demand for that
attention goes up what's terrible about
print and radio and direct mail is there
dying mediums they're not that there's
they're not doing as well as they used
to and you're paying the premium they
keep raising prices that's a macro
number you might be locally doing better
that's fine I don't know this is
interesting to me as business operator
spending money we have such a passion
for the past that we're willing to
overpay for something we know doesn't
work in lieu of something that's staring
us in the face and then we make fun of
venmo
or Robin Hood or rocket more a zebra
that we make fun of these things we do
we say these things and they're
marketing a completely different way and
they're growing by the second you're
making fun of them because you're not on
their team
the second you quit this job and go work
for them you're gonna sing its praises
you have vested interest it's like how I
talk about the Patriots I hate them
they're cheaters they're the worst I hit
everything I hope they all die [ __ ] them
I'm a Jets fan that's how I roll
but that's sports that's me talking
sports that's not real life you're doing
that in real life you're making real
life decisions based on not being on a
certain team guys this has happened
you're not gonna get a hundred million
dollar infusion into your tech stack
rebuild your app and your website to
create less friction tomorrow but what
you can do is take a real step back and
really start auditing every penny that
you spent there's no reason to waste
money because what I'm most worried
about is voice I will tell you it right
now I'm putting this on the record Caleb
where are you
you know Oh Caleb Caleb you know I film
all my content I like being historically
correct how many people here follow me
on Instagram couple hopeful thank you
you can see in the last six months I've
been doing the recall videos stuff I
said an 11 that became true this is my
currency over everything so I love
speaking for me could care less about me
the crowd one thing the truth the
current state of the truth
I don't sit up here and predict
everything you've heard in my mouth it's
things I've already seen happen this is
not guessing this is not futurist it's
not hoping this is everyday being a
practitioner spending a billion dollars
in ad money between my own agency and
the startups I'm involved with and my
own companies and watching how it all
plays by the way one of the weird things
to throw you for a loop
I think the Superbowl is the number one
thing everybody here should run in
marketing I think the Superbowl is the
most underpriced move in marketing
everybody in America will know what
you're up to whether they watch it on
YouTube or during the game another weird
one I'm starting to really pay attention
to the collapsing prices of Drivetime
radio right everybody's listening to
podcasts and Spotify I get that to me
it's not growing I just care if it's a
good deal I by the way I'll buy a
million television commercials next year
if they drop their prices by 85% so for
me I just really am desperate for
everybody to understand how real this is
because I've now lived more than two
decades of business have yelled about
this is gonna happen this is gonna
happen
people don't take it seriously
are not incentivized to or to careless
or you know and it's tougher for
employees I grew up back to when I used
to do it with entrepreneurs it was their
family business that made sense it's
hard for you to fight a machine that you
don't even own I get it but I will say
this and this is probably the single
best thing I can say in a room like this
for the future of your career the number
one thing I am passionate about is for
everybody in this room to consider the
value and the ROI of dot board for dying
on your own sword that was amazing that
it went out right when I was medicine
that was so amazing if you guys were
doing that in the back that was
unbelievable big shout out to them the
number one thing that I wish for all of
you is when you're sitting in a meeting
with senior executives or your marketing
team or your agencies and you're talking
about marketing if you have an opinion
that you believe in not because I said
it because you actually went home you
know if you're how many people here are
senior marketers in their company raise
your hands for only that just raise your
hand if you don't go home and spend 200
bucks on Facebook to try to sell
something that's sitting in your
basement on Facebook marketplace it
would be a huge mistake you can't have
opinions about something you don't know
you must be a practitioner please so let
me get to the point if you're in a
meeting tomorrow next week and we're
talking about Facebook or Instagram or
radio or television or print and you
have an opinion that's different than
what you as the professional is going
along with the ROI of you voicing that
opinion is that everybody else knows you
said it and it might not be valuable
today but when everything hits the fan
and it will in three or four years the
people that were historically correct
we'll get the first jobs that's real
life I've watched for too long over the
last decade friends of mine pander to
the companies that they worked in on
things they didn't believe only then to
feel the wrath when the company got hurt
and they didn't have the resume of
articulating their truth to protect them
and so they lost twice
if nothing else if nothing else this
morning
please in meetings talk about what you
actually believe in instead of what's
convenient for the short term because
the haves and have-nots of marketing are
becoming very clear the stakes are very
high let me bounce here for a couple
more minutes while I've got it one thing
to really understand and why so many
people are struggling with marketing
today is this is the greatest era of
math and art being equal partners
way too many marketers today either run
too much quant or they run too much art
this world too much quant math math math
right way too much not building brand
which is why voice is gonna be a problem
voice is gonna be a problem because
everything we now do on our mobile phone
over the next decade or two an enormous
percentage of that activity is going to
go to voice devices because it's faster
the only thing we value is speed we give
up there is no privacy concerns in
America we prove it every day we don't
care we care about convenience we like
time we like lack of friction it is
faster for me to say hey Alexa I'll take
two burgers and a fries then it is to
find my phone go to seemless and order
it many more transactions I grew up as a
kid that was told nobody would buy wine
on the internet that nobody would buy
tomatoes on the internet that nobody
would buy a car on the Internet we buy
all things on the Internet the Internet
is real life this is fake life and so
please understand the reason I'm pushing
brand the reason the Dwyane Wade thing
mattered is because building brand is
going to be the difference between
somebody saying Alexa sent me a case of
beer and Alexa send me Budweiser that is
going to be everything in the next
frontier and if you're a young executive
how many people here are retiring within
the next ten years and I don't mean that
you're gonna crush it and go buy a plane
I mean you're old and you're kind of
finished great great okay so for 9% of
this audience I will say this nothing
I'm saying is futurist it all matters
now but obviously as you can imagine for
the other 91% of this audience a decade
from now let me remind you that almost
nothing we talk about today existed a
decade and a half ago
nothing nothing this is going to
compound League row it's gonna get way
crazier and scarier if you don't like
this stuff and I desperately need you to
understand that the and this is actions
over words in a world where I could have
gone the VC route it had a lot of easy
life and lived it I wanted to build a
marketing machine to take advantage of
how big this is because I believe that
everything in our society is predicated
on communicating it's why dictators take
over the press when they first have a
coup communication matters and we are
living through the transition of
communication we have gone from a radio
first world to a television first world
we now actively live in a mobile device
world first that's just where we are and
when you look at the mobile phone the
far majority of activity besides gaming
and entertainment is on social networks
if your business does not know how to
communicate on those seven to ten
platforms every day your relevance of
brand is declining this is very
important this is not hahaha fun
this is massively disruptive and the
naivete that I've seen from governments
and politicians and other big companies
and different sectors is happening here
right now in this industry I have a
first view at it it's why I love working
with Chase so much Krishna LEM Cal was
one of the most progressive thoughtful
CMOS period that I work with let alone
in this sector pushing the envelope
around relevance of brand whether it's
Serena and curry for that kind of
cultural stuff whether it's the tactics
of eliminating all those banner ads that
we used to buy she's on it sharpest
attack and she's in an ivory tower at
the biggest companies in the world many
people here in the trenches should know
can absolutely do this I think you need
to have a call in arms this
has to be the morning we have to
scrutinize the money we're spending we
have to scrutinize the reports that we
are held accountable that everybody here
knows don't actually match to the
reality of our business
and we have to put pressure on the most
senior executives that sit on boards and
see suites that pontificate about the
past or asking for ROI within a minute
of the spend because all those behaviors
that I just mentioned are the singular
reasons that great companies that make
tons of profit
wake up seven years later and are no
longer in business please please heed
this it's coming because it's already
here thank you
[Music]
you